President Trump is threatening to pull
us funding from the World Health
Organization the w-h-o sent out multiple
coronavirus alerts earlier this year in
fact declaring it a global health
emergency back in January the president
largely dismissed those warnings saying
also in January it's going to be just
fine that's a direct quote now has been
Tracie reports mr. Trump claims the
w-h-o failed they call it wrong they
really they missed the call the
president is shifting blame for the
spread of the corona virus to the World
Health Organization saying it should
have provided better warnings it didn't
report it if they did see they must have
seen it but they didn't report it the
organization labeled coronavirus a
global health emergency in January I'm
declaring a public health emergency of
international concern meanwhile the
president says he was not aware of memos
written by his trade adviser Peter
Navarro in late January in February that
warned of a full-blown kovat 19 pandemic
that could infect 100 million Americans
hurt he wrote some memos talking about
pandemic I didn't see him any to look
for him either
the President did ban most travel from
China and formed a coronavirus task
force in late January but then down late
the threat publicly I think it's gonna
be under control the president now says
he did not want to alarm the country he
said within a couple of days cases will
be down to zero
how much cheerleader for this country I
don't want to create havoc and shock and
everything else but ultimately when I
was saying that I'm also closing it down
I obviously was concerned about it for
CBS this morning Ben Tracy the White
House